und auch diese geschichte müsse sie
heute an diesem dienstag einfach kennen
live protest im putin tv das ist am
abend im russischen staatsfernsehen
passiert diese szene hier bisher läuft
roman und bekommen
eine frau meine mitarbeiter sind von dem
fernsehsender kommt rein mit und dann
wird ganz schnell diese bilder
eingeblendet mit krankenhaus szenen aber
lassen ist doch man schaut euch doch die
der stadt
kein krieg kein krieg und dann ganz
schnell programm wird abgebrochen damit
man das in putins propagandasender bloß
nicht sehen kann millionen russen
scheint da ein ja aber es war in dem
moment ausgestrahlt alles live was für
eine geschichte was für eine mutige frau
wir schauen uns dieses plakat noch mal
genau an was sie reihen gehalten hat
also nova das können wir alle lesen kein
krieg und dann schreibt sie darunter
eben hier wird gelogen das ist
propaganda was hier passiert das stimmt
nicht was hier gesendet wird das
schreibt diese mitarbeiterin dieses
fernsehsenders mutig auf dieses plakat
hält das live zur besten sendezeit ins
russische staatsfernsehen hier wird
gerade gelogen über diesen krieg
der ihr name ist martina
sablikova verzeihung und sie ist
ukrainerin halb ukrainerin und russen
und wurde dann direkt nach der sendung
auch festgenommen das wusste sie
natürlich denn zu kriegsbeginn wurden da
die strafen noch mal deutlich erhöht ihr
war klar es geht danach sie sofort in
ein gefängnis und deswegen hat sie
vorher eine videobotschaft aufgezeichnet
die wir eben hier auch zeigen wollen
dass das was in der ukraine gerade
passiert ist ein verbrechen und russland
ist in diesem fall ein aggressor die
verantwortung für diese aggression
lasten auf dem gewissen von einem
einzigen menschen und dieser mensch ist
vladimir putin mit foto carina meine
mutter ist russin sie waren die feinde
leider habe ich in den letzten jahren
für den ersten kanal gearbeitet und
keine propaganda gemacht jetzt stehe ich
mich sehr dafür ich schäme mich weil ich
es zugelassen habe die lügen im
fernsehen zu verbreiten ich schäme mich
dafür weil ich es zugelassen habe den
russischen menschen das gehirn zu
waschen wir haben 2014 geschwiegen als
das ganze angefangen hat wie sie nicht
auf die straßen gegangen als kreml
navalny vergiftet hat wir haben
schweigen diesen menschenfeindlichen
verschiedene zugeschaut
beruf die russische menschen denken du
um kluge menschen nur wir können diesen
wahnsinn stoppen geht auf die
demonstration habt keine angst sie
können uns nicht alle verhaften
das ist sie diese mutige ja in der
ukraine geborene frauen und deshalb an
sie die kette gesehene sieht man nämlich
auch die russischen und den ukrainischen
farben und in dem video von watsons geht
es für jeden fall gezeigt haben dankt er
auch dieser frau für ihren mut die ja
auch weitere auffordert er zu
protestieren etwas das in russland unter
strafe steht lass uns über diese frau
sprechen die heute die welt fasziniert
hoffentlich ganz ganz viele millionen
russen am abend gesehen haben
hoffentlich ihre wahrheit ganz klar an
den bildschirmen verfolgt haben wir
sprechen darüber mit fiat auf der das
natürlich auch gesehen hat unser bild
reporter aktuell in lemberg was glaubst
du wie viel millionen russen haben das
gestern verfolgt das ist sozusagen
putins propaganda tagesschau wenn ich
das mal so übersetzen darf also das
kommt tatsächlich in viele haushalte
ganz genau das ist der größte russische
fernsehen kanal der erste kanal der hat
eine marktabdeckung von fast 100 prozent
und bei einer bevölkerung von knapp 140
millionen menschen kann man sich
vorstellen dass das dutzende millionen
waren die hier am bildschirm saßen und
wenigstens für einige sekunden sehen
konnten dass es protest gibt und zwar
nicht nur protest von den üblichen
verdächtigen also von der wange und
seinen unterstützern oder von
irgendwelchen demonstranten in moskau
und sankt petersburg sondern von
jemandem innerhalb des systems innerhalb
eines fernsehkanals dem sie eigentlich
vertrauen nun von dem sie eigentlich
gewöhnt sind dass es nur kreml treue ist
zu hören und zu sehen gibt
ich habe gerade darüber gesprochen es
steht unter strafe das war ihr klar und
diese strafen die wurden ja auch nochmal
verhärtet dann zu kriegsbeginn was genau
droht der frau jetzt
ihr können jetzt bis zu mehreren jahren
haft drohen aber es ist alles noch
völlig unklar weil man keine anwälte zu
ihr vor lässt also die organisation von
alexei navalny hat sofort angekündigt
dass man bereit ist jegliche strafe für
sie zu bezahlen und auch an alle anderen
redakteure die so etwas machen es gibt
menschenrechtsorganisationen die
natürlich sofort ihre anwälte hin
geschickt haben aber auch die wurden
nicht zu ihr gelassen und jetzt ist die
frage wie der kreml damit umgeht wird er
versuchen das einfach runter zu spielen
nach dem motto an alles nur ein
einzelfall oder wird er durchgreifen und
an ihr ein exempel statuieren ehrlich
gesagt wenn man sich den kreml bislang
anschaut hat er noch nie auf
deeskalation gesetzt auch nicht bei
solchen fällen das heißt es ist davon
auszugehen dass man versuchen wird etwas
abschreckendes zu tun er eine möglichst
hohe gefängnisstrafe aufzubrummen damit
andere bloß nicht auf die idee kommen so
etwas nachzumachen kann man was tun für
die frau jetzt hier im westen also
könnten sich jetzt politiker dafür
einsetzen der kanzler wir alle haben
diese szenen ja heute gesehen und sind
total bewegt davon
ja natürlich ist das schön wenn man sich
mit der frau solidarisiert aber seien
wir ehrlich wir haben uns alle mit
alexei navalny solidarisiert und
herausgekommen ist nichts der mann ist
seit über einem jahr im gefängnis und
generali ist immerhin der prominente
russische oppositionspolitiker
das heißt ich glaube nicht dass man viel
tun kann der kreml hört nicht auf den
westen der kreml wähnt sich ihr kriegt
uns und wenn wir uns jetzt mit der
brause solidarisieren schadet der kreml
ganz sicher nicht auf die idee kommen
acht dann lassen wir sie doch noch
davonkommen ich glaube da ist ehrlich
gesagt viel verloren was glaubst würde
dieser aktion bei den russen und
russinnen aufgenommen wurde da
vielleicht für den einen oder anderen
klar was da wirklich passiert wurde da
dem einen oder anderen klar wie viel
propaganda er eigentlich unterliegt in
den medien in russland oder glaubst du
dass sie einfach als störenfried
wahrgenommen wird und morgen ist das
thema schon wieder ein ganz anderes
ich glaube nicht dass man mit dieser
einen kurzen aktion diese ganze
propaganda wieder gut machen kann wenn
man muss sich russland so vorstellen
dass in den vergangenen acht jahren also
seit der friedlichen revolution in der
keiner sei 2014 die bevölkerung
massivster propaganda beschallung
unterzogen wird das heißt es wird ihnen
seit acht jahren jeden tag gesagt dass
die ukraine irgendwelche faschisten
regieren dass das alles vom besten
kontrolliert wird und dass die ukraine
ein krieg gegen russland vorbereitet hat
das alles kann man nicht wieder gut
machen mit ein paar sekunden das
wichtige symbol ist dass das jemand
getan hat der zu diesem system gehört
also es war nicht irgendein krimmel
kritisches medium von dem man weiß in
russland das sind die vom westen
gesteuerten das denken das ja ganz viele
russen sondern das war jemand der zu
diesem ersten kanal gehört den
vertrauenswürdigsten größten kanal in
russischen medien landschaft und wenn
die menschen sehen dass selbst dort
menschen sich trauen zu widersprechen
kann das einige zum nachdenken bringen
und natürlich macht das auf sehr vielen
menschen mut dass eine frau eine junge
frau die auch jederzeit auch einfach
auswandern könnte nein dass sie sich
hinstellt um die wahrheit zu sagen und
dort auch eine hohe gefängnisstrafe
riskiert also es kann sehr viele
nachahmer eventuell zur folge haben der
erste kanal hat auch schon sofort
reagiert und
überprüft jetzt wer überhaupt während
live sendung ins studio darf das heißt
da wird das vermutlich heftige gesinnung
schecks noch mal geben damit es sich so
etwas nicht wiederholt und es wird
vermutlich einfach niemand mehr von aus
der redaktion in diesem raum gelassen
ins studio philipp ita für uns aus
lemberg zugeschaltet dort im westen der
ukraine wir sind hinter dir auch das
straßenbild der stadt ist es schön auch
mal diese bilder aus dem land zu sehen
bist du ein bisschen lesen und über
straßen herrscht danke dir